Unable to make their own toxins,
these females resort to drinking the blood
of other fireflies to get these protective chemicals.
So a firefly vampire,
brought to you by natural selection.
We still have a lot to learn about fireflies,
but it looks like many stories will remain untold,
because around the world, firefly populations
are blinking out.
The main culprit: habitat loss.
Pretty much everywhere, the fields and forests,
the mangroves and meadows that fireflies need to survive,
are giving way to development and to sprawl.
Here's another problem: we've conquered darkness,
but in the process, we spill so much extra light out into the night
that it disrupts the lives of other creatures,
and fireflies are especially sensitive to light pollution
because it obscures the signals
that they use to find their mates.
Do we really need fireflies?
After all, they're just one tiny bit
of Earth's biodiversity.
Yet every time a species is lost,
it's like extinguishing a room full of candles
one by one.
You might not notice
when the first few flames flicker out,
but in the end, you're left sitting in darkness.
As we work together to craft a planetary future,
I hope we can find a way
to keep these bright lights shining.
Thank you.
(Applause)